だから異常欲になると
もう生きていられなくなっちゃいますね
で 実現できないんでしょ？異常欲は
だから苦しみだけで終わっちゃうんです
だから初めから頭おかしいでしょうに
次から次へと叩かれると頭が
さらにさらに頭がイカレてイカレてイカレてイカレて
もうもうどうにもならないこと
もう治らない状態になってしまうのです
だから現代人が仏教に興味がないと言ったって別にいいんです
治れないんです もう治せないんです
あまりにも もうもう病気です
だからこの異常欲という引っ掛けがあると
その人々は確実に輪廻転生するんですよ
それで苦しみがずっとついてくるんです
キリがなく これ異常欲のヘリコプターっていうのは
あのたまたまね  100万人に
あるいは 1000万人に一人ぐらい
ちょっとうまくいったら
それが例にするんですね
じゃあ私もだってあの人はとどこまで
例えば石川遼っていう子供の時はもうすごい
やっぱりうちの子もそうやってほしいとかね
ありえないんですけど
なんたかどうかの音楽コンクールでね
日本の人がね まあ 1 になりますって
それならうちの子ももうもう専門だからとか何か
それはちょっとありえないんです
もう地球の中 人間の本能の程度だから
だから逆にその人々に異常欲あったかというと
それもないでしょう どこまで頭がおかしいんですかね
石川遼が世界一になるって
それ異常欲ないんです
本人が持っている能力をどんどんどんどん出していきたいだけで
あのコンドルのあのコンクールで勝ったあの目が見えない人にしても
ただ自分でそれしかできんだからそれやっただけであって
楽しいと これでもうもう勝利
勝利というんですか 優勝になってね
それで話が終わりますけど
その人に別に異常欲あったわけじゃないんです
これでみんな母親たちがね
うちの子もそれに出そうと思っちゃうと
どうなることかと だからいつでもそういう稀な何かケースを見て
我々仏教徒はすごく悲観的ではないかと
もうポジティブで見れば
何さん何さん何さんもそうなったんじゃないかと
私 でもあなたはなりませんよ
ただ それぞれの人が自分を持っている能力を発揮するだけで
だから私たちは石川と一緒になるんじゃなくて
我々も何かもう能力を持っているならば
それを発揮すればそれで話が終わります
けど 異常よく割り込むと
その持っている能力は発揮しないんですね
それであえてあえて頭イカれちゃって
苦しみから苦しみに 苦しみから苦しみへと
はいいんだけど このこの拡大するんですね
無制限に苦しむ そこまで苦しまなくてもいいんですよ
本当にほんの少々生きることはどうしても苦しいんだから
それだったら最低限での苦しみで十分でしょうに
これは最低限ではなくて
もう最大限で苦しむと
これ以上苦しみないのかと
さらにも探すんだから
そういうことでこの引っ掛け第1は異常欲アビッジャカーヤガンタというんです
カーヤガンタというのはシステム的に引っかかっているんです
これは心が 次ヴィーラーパーラ
ヴィーラーパーラ カーヤガンタ
ヴィーラーパーラっていうのはまた異常怒りですね
いやだこれはって程度じゃないんです
何かしらものを運ぼうとと
あまりにも重くて運べない
いやだ これ重くて置いておきますと
なんとか運ぶ方法ないのかと
その程度の怒りじゃないんですね
我々にあるのは  [背景音]だから怒りも欲と同じく頭が狂ってしまって
大変な苦しみを呼び起こすることになりますね
はい  3番目はシーラッブとバラマース
で これは一般人には関係ない引っ掛けなんですけど
しかし引っ掛けはあるんです
この生きることって何やとかね
精神って何やとかね 死んでどうなるのかとかね
あれこれやと この人生について考える連中もいます
この世の中で 数は少ないんだけど
いわゆる生きる道場って宗教を選ぶという
どんな国でもいるんです
で なかなかそういう人々がいても何もできないのは国 2つ北朝鮮と日本だけなんですけど
他の国では一応そういう他のお仕事をやりたくないとね
宗教的な精神的なことをやりたいと思って
まぁやったりする 西洋でも教会に入って神父になったり
その学校に入って勉強して普通の仕事もできますよ
大学校に入って弁護士になったり
工学校工学エンジニアになったりとかね
できますけど もう全部それは嫌やと
言って そういう 別世界に興味を持つ人間っていうのはいるんです
昔からいましたし これは人間の中ではごくごく普通の現象なんです
しかし 数は少ないんですけど
昔 インドでもそういうことはありましたし
現代でも世の中でいくらでもそういう人々は出てくる
だから どんな人間の中にも精神的なことに興味ある人がいるんだからって
日本でもいますよ ただ
その人々には道がない
日本のお寺に入ったらどうでしょうか
お寺に入ったら差別されます
やられます 寺の息子でなきゃということになりますから
これ相当おかしいんですけど
仏道は閉鎖していますと
ある家族の財産であると
もう仏教ひとかけらの特色ないんです
オープンな教えなのに
親から息子に行くものじゃないんです
仏教は 師匠から弟子には行きますけど
それも弟子が学んで修行しなきゃダメなんです
例えば中国の禅宗では
あの禅師が亡くなると
禅師の息子が次の禅師になりません
弟子の一番上もなりません
修行を進んで それなりの精神的な境地に達している人を次の禅師として認可するのです
それが仏教的なんです
で 普通常識的でも同じです
日本の最高裁判官が引退すると
息子が次の座に ありえないでしょう
なのに なんで宗教でそうなるんですかね
例えば日銀の総裁と言うんですか
日銀の総裁の任期が終わったら
娘か息子が次の総裁になる
なんで宗教でそうなるんですかね
だから完全に詐欺なんです
これが 王家と天皇家とは違います
それはもう決まってますからね
もう血縁でもう息子か娘だっていうことはね
それも正しくない 仏教から見れば王さえも息子に行くんじゃないよとお釈迦様おっしゃってるんです
資格取れよ だからジャータカ物語はもう現実世界できないからジャータカ物語でやりたい放題やってます
王様を追い出す物語とかね
そこら辺の白鳥さんが王に認定する話とか
ジャータカ物語であるんです
だからそれは仏教が言いたかったポイントなんです
白鳥さんであってもね
もう資格があるならば
あんたはどうするのかと
国を治める能力があるんだったら
その人でやるしかないでしょう
だから 俗世間では王家の人々は一応血縁で言っちゃいますけど
それさえも仏教は認めないんです
能力なかったらもうダメだと
やめやめやめさせなさいという仏教なんですよ
まぁとにかく世の中ではそういうね
まぁどうせ悪行 悪行為しないと認められませんだからね
まぁまぁいいんだけど
人々は人間の中で 日本でもやっぱり会社の社員でも人生じゃなくても
もっと何かもう精神的なことで何かないかなというふうに思う人々は一応います
で 日本と韓国以外 北朝鮮と日本以外は
やっぱりその人々にもいろんな道があるんですね
韓国でもありますよ お寺に入りたければ入られますし
教会に入るだけでは入られます
まぁ ソ連ではできます
あの中国でもできます
共産主義だと言ったってもね
あまり断りませんよ 政府に文句言わない限りは
もう一応自由で活動できます
当然台湾でもできます
だからイギリス ソ連 ロシア
アメリカ どこでも ヨーロッパどこでも
一応そういう人々にも入られるような道がありますよ
だから この 3番目のきっかけは
その人々の世界でよく見えてくるんです
俗世間の人々はまだそこまで成長してもないんです
1番目で十分やられているんです
1番目  2番  1番目でもう終わり
もうゲームオーバーなんです
そこでもうやられない人は怒りでやられちゃうんです
そこでもパスだったら 3番目でやられちゃいます
宗教の世界は 3番目でやられます
3番目はシーラッブとパラマサナです
えっとえっとえっと 戒禁でしたっけ？戒禁
戒禁衆とこちら書いてますか
あれこれとしきたり 儀式
形式的なものに縛られます
そういうことで このそういう宗教的な世界に入り込んだら
あらゆる儀式 儀礼で一生終わってしまうんです
じゃあ密教はなんですかね？ティベット密教はなんですかね？何かやる暇がありますかね
あの人々に 朝早く起きて呪文唱えるは
儀式やるは 法螺を吹くは
ドラを叩くは そればっかしでしょ
最近どうかわかりません
日本でも仏教には興味あった時期がありますけど
みんな密教 仏教に興味を持って
ティベット密教に アメリカでも仏教に興味あります
何かというと ティベット仏教に興味があるだけ
全然知識人というわけじゃないんです
なんでティベット仏教に惹かれたかというと
儀式 儀礼 号泣ってあるんですね
それしか何もないんです
呪文 呪文 何にも呪文 何でも呪文があります
あの第一悟るためにはこの呪文
第三遍にこの呪文 如来になるためにはこの呪文とかね
一回このカヤナク会館で私は喋っていた時でも
前の日かその同じ日でお見せした若い坊主が来て
チベットのね もう 2万円ぐらいの寺を払わせたかったんですけど
すっごいなんだらなんだらちんぽのちゅうかなんとか言って
それで私はちらっと顔を見て
何この野郎と思ったんですけどね
で 私はちょっと顔を出した時で
悟りに達する呪文か何とか呪文を教えているんですね
悟りに達する呪文まであるのに
チベット民族を解放する呪文が持ってないでしょ
私それ欲しいんです チベット民族がもう自由になって
自分 自分のね 民族的に中国の一部であっても
もうチベット民族は自分なりに幸せで平和で生きていられるために
その呪文ないんです しかし
如来になりたければもう呪文があります
病気治したければもう呪文があります
が 病院も必要です なんだこれと
希望叶うためにも呪心呪文ありますけど
ダルマサラの学校とか難民キャンプ運営するために世界から資金を出さなくちゃいけないんですね
なんで呪文でやらないんですかね
まあよくわからないんですね
私は それでアメリカ人もそこ好きなんですね
で 菩提 お釈迦様の菩提樹のあるところに行ったっても
アメリカの女性たちがこの前見ましたけど
もうチベット密教の呪文唱えながらもういろいろやっています
さすがアメリカでも仏教を広げているそうかとかね
みんな喜んだりしますけどね
まぁ法律の問題ながら
私は一応けり 蹴りたくない
呪文唱える曼荼羅を描いてもう貼ってもらって
結局例えば曼荼羅描く場合
真面目に本物の曼荼羅描く場合
どれくらい時間かかると思いますかね
あれすっごくきめ細かいんだからね
1本1本手で丁寧に描かなくちゃいけないんですよ
あの あの やり直ししないで
あ 間違った まあ消そうと
それもダメです 正しく描くならば
だからかもしれませんよ
いくら曼荼羅見ていて
呪文唱えても 誰一人も微塵も成長しないのは
いわゆる本物の曼荼羅は描けないんです
間違っちゃいます それで直すんです
それで終わり あの砂で作る曼荼羅はね
もう一応 作るためにはもう 1ヶ月間ぐらいかかります
だから結局能力的に見れば見事な腕ですよ
たった砂を吹き込むだけ
ものすごく美しく もう砂だけで作っちゃいます
3ヶ月間ぐらいかけて
それから儀式をやって
全部それで作り出しちゃう
それで大量に砂を運んで川に流す
あれいい作品だからね
ボンドで固めて置いた方が
私ならそうしますよ あの樹脂
なんとかボンドありますね
あれでキシーってスプレーかけちゃえば
透明だからしっかり固めるんで
結構砂で作ったものだから
作品としては価値がありますけど
宗教としては 0 でしょうに
頭がイカれて だからそういう人々には作品として
芸術家としては腕がいいんだけど
イコール宗教じゃないんです
そこでポイントは そういう方々は
例えば正直なものがその世界に入っても
あの儀式 儀礼 しきたり
習慣 呪文などなどに断食
滝行 あれこれに引っかかってしまうんです
それで普通の人間と同じく輪廻転生なんです
何のこともないんです
あんた今死にたい？いいえ
まだ悟りに達してないんだからと
みんな菩薩たちだから
だから論理的にも旅を
旅の目的達することは無限に延期ということにしてるんです
特に大乗仏教はね 一切所作を作ってから悟りますからね
だからもうイスラム教より仏教から見れば邪教なんです
一切所作を作って悟りに達するぞと言っちゃうと
なんか物の見事に騙されます
あれ すごいなと思っちゃうでしょ
すごいんです 気持ちは当たるのは当然です
問題は現実になる時なんですよ
私が自分が悟らないで
あなた悟れ あなた悟れ
あなた悟れと頑張ってるでしょ
みんなに迷惑かけやがってるんですね
それでその人も私ももう一切所作だから
あなた悟りなさい いや
あなた悟りなさい 誰一人悟りに達しないでしょう
だから欲のそういう概念
なんで明確に屁理屈なのに
明確におかしいなのに
なんでそんなにそういう妄想概念作って派手に発達させて文化にしてしまって
もう 500年  600年も生き続けたりして
それなりに歴史的にも価値付けたりして捨てられないようにしていますかというと
やられてますよ この 3番目のあれで
だから欲がありすぎて
ありすぎて輪廻転生しちゃって悟れなかったっていうことは
ことはそれほどカッコ悪くないんです
みんなのことだからね
でもこの人々の方がどれほどカッコ悪いかというと
ということですね  4番目に入ります
戒禁集と読むんですね
仏教は ずいぶん簡単な言葉に
3番目はイダン・サッチャービ・ニメーサというパーリ語なんですけど
4番目ですね  4番目 これが日本訳はできないんですから
意味だけ書いてますね
悪見に基づき自分の見解が正しいと固執するという
だから悪見に基づき 基づきということはちょっと余計
それ取りまして 意味は自分の見解が正しいと
正しいと固執することなんです
悪見に基づきっていうのはもういらん
それは念のために丁寧に書いてるだけで
皆様はこの自分の見解に
見解が正しいと固執することが 4番目の引っかかりなんです
これが一番きついんです
これには仏教徒もハメられます
ブッダの教えを知っている人なら
三番目からももうさようならできますよ
四番目はどうするのかと
それには引っかからない生命はないんです
一番手強い 何のことない
自分の意見は正しい それだけ
これは矛盾でも何でもないんですよ
我々には正しくない見解を作ることは不可能なんです
だから見解が作ったらそれは正しいんです
自分にとっては どうしようもないでしょう
例えばこちら花が咲いてありまして
これ何色で 紫と言うんですか
で こちらの誰に聞いても紫の花ですと
紫色の花ですという見解になるんです
いや これは真っ白なバラですと誰も言わないでしょう
口で冗談で言っても 心は知っています
紫の花に決まってるんだと
だから これを見て紫の花ですということも見解ですよ
正しいでしょ それが それで我々の頭で生まれる一切の概念は何であろうとも見解なんです
これ自分にとっては正しいんです
だから解放 解放できるんですかね
それからは 自由になれますかね
旦那さんが不倫したんだからもう嫌いになりましたと
思ってる奥さんにそんなこと言わないで好きになりなさい
前と同じこと やってくれる？できないんですよ
自分の見解は正しいと思っちゃうんです
俺 離婚するぞと それで幸福になること
でもそんなことしたらあんた子育てどうするんですか？と
なんとか費 何と言いますか？教育費
養育費  養育費もらいますよと言ったっても
日本でもね 裁判でいうか
なんとか話し合ってて決めるでしょうに
その場合は男の経済能力で適当な値段つけるのであって
養育費は 1000万かかるんだからといって 1000万出せと言ったら
結構離婚も成立しませんだからね
それで 200万円で  200万円で手を打つんでしょうに
なんでこの現実見えないんですかね
あなた 200万円で子育てできますかと
そんなの 2年で飛んじゃいますから
あのお金は  でも変えませんね
いくら言ってもあの考え方は
変えませんではなくて変えられないんですよ
理屈でわかっても もう二度とあの男と一緒にいたくないという気持ちが出てくるんです
ギャーギャー言うと もうあなた言ってることはわかりますけど
だからといってあの男とは一緒にはもう生活できんと
どうしますかね その場合
そこでポイントは私の見解は正しいということなんです
そこを破ることっていうのはいとも簡単です
本当は だってそう思ってるのはその人だけでしょ
この男とは絶対生活一緒に生活したくないと思ってるのは
その女一人だけでしょ
その男のお母さんに聞いたっても
兄弟に聞いてみたっても
その女の人の妹に聞いてみたっても
まあいいんじゃないかという感じでしょうね
なのに なのに自分の見解は変えられないんですよ
だからとってもシンプルに破られますよ
ちょっと調べたら あるいは逆に世の中で不倫したっても
後でお互い仲直りして謝って
元の妻に戻って また死ぬまで一緒に子供育てて幸せにいる家族はいないのかと調べたら
いくらでも出るわ出るわ出るわ出るわ
もしかするとほとんど家族葬ではないかというぐらいは証拠出るなのに
この人はもう変えられません
でしょ だからこの見解破るということは
そんなに大変なことじゃないんです
しかし 今私が言ったところは
この理論的なところだけ
理論でわかっても気持ちは変わらないんですね
そこは気持ちまで持っていっちゃうんです
見解は持たないんだよと
持ったら馬鹿やと 持てないんだと
見解っていうのは で見解なら持てないんだと知るためには
ありのままの真理を知る羽目になるんです
だから 4番目の引っ掛けを破った人が当たり前に悟り達しています
悟りの中でも第1なんですね
その場合は 喜びに達しています
だから喜びに立って 地味な真剣な仏教徒であっても
これでやられています
輪廻転生はします だからもう真理を発見したら
ありのままの事実を見えたら見解成り立ちませんよと
発見すればそれで OK
それで悟りに達しています
それで喜びに達しますから
それでもう自動ででも心に悟りには達して解脱は終了
旅は終わったことになります
このガンタ 引っ掛け フック
は 4つ それでその偈の意味は終わりだと思います
で パリラーホーノイッジャティっていうのは
このパリラーハっていうのは
こちらの訳では煩悩という熱は存在しないと訳してますね
パリラーハとは 我々の言語ではよく使う単語なんですけど
なんか燃えてる状態なんですね
胸焼けとか病気あるでしょ
あんな感じで心も焼けますね
トラブルあると 相当きついんですよ
だから悩みなどなど なんかあんまり軽すぎ
そういう単語はね パリラーハ
英語で言えばバーニングということですね
だからフィジカルバーニングではなくて
エモーショナルバーニング
で バーニングという単語で思い出したのは
中森明菜でしたっけ？歌
なんで日本人英語の歌に英語の単語入れるんですかね
あれは大嫌いですけど
私の意見誰も聞かないんですね
で 発音できんでしょ？ Burning Heart というね
だからバーニハーと言うんですね
バーニハーって何や？これ
英語発音できる人ならすごく美しく発音するはずなんですけど Heart
と言わないんだから 最後のT言わないで発音できんだからね
バーニハーで終わっちゃうんです
だから歌は本当にすごい能力あって
歌自体悪くないんだけど
あれ聴けると気持ち悪い
もう歌詞は立派なんですけど
あのバーニハー捨ててくれた
またその歌のポイントもそれなんですね
まあとにかくあの まあそこに出てくるような感じで
この我々心がもういろんな問題で燃えている状態ですね
そんなのはありえないんだと
わかった人にとっては
旅終わった人にとってはと
そういうことで ヨガチャラで表現したのは
阿羅漢 仏教が語る理想の境地は何なのかとという中身の説明なんです
相当大変ですよ もう全て生命の真理をもう牛耳りしてあって
真理をわかっているんですね
冗談じゃないんです だからそれからもう一つ
我々正直に死にたくはないんですね
悟りに達したら その気持ちはものの見事に消えちゃいます
何も疑いもなく だから
もしかすると私は悟ったんではないかということを僕
成田寺まで 結構しつこく私に言う人もいます
認定出しなさいと 今これここまでやりましたからと
毎日2時間やってるんだからね
それで十分でしょうと
私認定出せる資格ないと知らないんです
ないんで お釈迦様も認定しませんよ
お釈迦様本人が悟ったら
あの人は悟ってますよと自分でやって
お釈迦様なら言うんだけど
サーリプッタ尊者もモクレン尊者も言わないこと
私に言えると思ってるんですかね
私があなたは女である男だって認定する？私は認定しなかったら
男は女になる 女は男になる
何考えてるんですかね
悟ったら誰の認定もいらん
だから私たちにはそこはすごいわかりやすい論理でしょうに
生きていきたいということはあるでしょうに
いわゆるまだ旅が終わってないんですね
死にたくないという気持ちあるでしょうに
それで 旅が終わったらその気持ちがそれで綺麗さっぱりなくなるんです
自殺願望を言われたとかアホな話じゃないんです
あんまりにもこれすごい高次元の話なんです
しかし 本人にとっては明確なことなんです
そういうことで あの話は終わりです
次々あの省略するあのことで
あの第一偈は明確に解説するんです
それからあの まあ参考にして
いきます 今日はこれで終わりますけど
それで本物のブッダの言葉っていうのは
一行二行で全て完成しているんです
今日の二行を見ても 全て真理を語っています
二行で それが本物のブッダの言葉なんです
ブッダ以外誰にも語れません
そういう だからこの比較にならないブッダの言葉っていうのは
似てない他宗教とも タテスカとも
際立って優れて輝いているんです
誰にも編集も何もできません
理解はできます それで
なんで私はこんなに大胆に
ものすごい乱暴で解説するのかというと
怖くないんです 言葉は正しいんです
それで自信があるだけの話です
しかし この場合は何のこともないんです
何の躊躇もなく言える勇気が出ているんです
それなぜかというと ブッダの言葉が真理だからなんです
もうかなわないんです
誰にも こんなにまとめて言えるのかと
はい そういうことで 大体まあ一応お釈迦様の純粋なね
言葉勉強するところですから
まあ今日は私の話は終わりですが
あの 何か質問等あるならばね
[笑い]